字幕: Takuma Suzuki
校正: Kazunori Akashi
（山田）運命の針が動き出したという言葉を
私はよく耳にします
でも 今 このステージに立って
確信しました
今まさにこの瞬間が
運命の針がスタートしたんです
というのも 時間というのは
誰に対しても平等にやってきます
同じ時間軸で動いています
そう 常に針は動き続けているんです
ただ あえてこのTEDxSapporoのステージ
そして目の前にいる皆さんの顔
この一緒の時間を共有していくということで
運命の針が動き出したのは
今まさにこの瞬間だと私は思っております
（田村）山さん 山さん
（山田）ハイハイ
（田村）めっちゃ皆さん真剣に聞いて
頷いてくださってますけど
単純に持ち時間が進んでるってことでしょ
（山田）そうです
ただ単純にタイマーが動き始めた
（田村）済みませんね
（金田）普通のこと言ってるよね
（田村）それを言いたかっただけです
（山田）ただただ 普通のことです
でも 普通のことを
大事にしていきたいわけです
（田村）そうだね
（山田）まずはHAMBURGER BOYSのね
音楽で皆さんを温めていきたいと思います
お届けしましょう『NANTE HOT』
（音楽）
それじゃあ みなさん
手拍子 手をたたいていきましょう
体にビートを流し込んで
あったかいよ なんてHOT 心からホッと
伝わる気持ちが Feelin’ Good
あったかいの なんてHOT 教えて欲しいよ
今日が明日へと繋がっていく
la la la
(宴会で食う肉 分けて食うのね エチケット)
あのビルももうすっかり見た目サッパリ
見慣れた姿も遠い彼方に
そんな僕も四十路間近で
記憶力低下するよ一方
やりたいことは増える傾向 (Ho)
やれることも増えてる結構 (Ho)
同じようなモチベーションを持った
友達 仲間が出来たり
すごいことさ続ける事は
どっかの誰かが言ってた言葉
不確かな未来はまだ見ぬ空
確かな事は今日も生きてる
今日がどんな一日だったのか
今週はこんな事があったとか
何気ない事でも教えて欲しい
そこに感じるよ温もり
(ハイじゃあ One Two Step
もういっちょ One Two Step)
君と住むならベッドタウン
ローカルいいじゃない
(ハイじゃあ One Two Step
もういっちょ One Two Step)
変わりゆく事 それもいいよね
あったかいよ なんてHOT 心からホッと
伝わる気持ちが Feelin’ Good
あったかいの なんてHOT 教えて欲しいよ
今日が明日へと繋がっていく
la la la
(宴会で食う肉 分けて食うのね エチケット)
(宴会で食う肉)
サンキュー どうもありがとう
(拍手)
（山田）改めまして HAMBURGER BOYSです
（田村）HAMBURGER BOYSです
（田村）よろしくお願いします
（山田）よろしくお願いします
お届けしたナンバーはHAMBURGER BOYSの
『NANTE HOT』という曲で
NHK『ほっとニュース北海道』の
テーマソングとして 今使われております
もしかしたら 聞いたことがあるよ
という方もいるのかなと思いますけども
今日は本当に皆さんもね
『NANTE HOT』という
タイトルに合わせて
本当に温かい拍手をいただきました
本当にあったかいですね
（田村）ありがとうございます
（山田）しっかり着込んでいるしね
（田村）だから暖かいわけじゃないんですよ
そんな着込んでないですし 皆様
どっちかと言えば薄着ですよ
（山田）やっぱり情報を共有するのって
素晴らしいですよね
（田村）何でしょう
（山田）必ず僕これ言いますからって
もうリハーサルで３回ぐらい
やったんですよ このくだり
（田村）やめなさいよ
（山田）ちゃんと
（田村）初めてだからね こういう風に
山田さんがボケることを事前に言ってきたのは
（山田）そうですね
はい そんなHAMBURGER BOYS
改めてボーカルの山田です
そしてギター
（田村）はい ギター田村次郎です
よろしくお願いします
（山田）お願いします
DJ
（金田）はい DJの金田ヒデミです
よろしくお願いします
（山田）HAMBURGER BOYSと
言いますけれども ４人それぞれ
（田村）４人
（山田）あれ増えちゃった
（田村）山田さん ３人です
（金田）マジで間違える
（山田）目の前で今HAMBURGER BOYSを
見てくれているあなたをカウントして
（田村）初めてじゃんそれ
（金田）どんな言い訳だよそれ
（山田）正式には３名です
（田村）３名ですね
（山田）ただ ボーイズと言っても
もう40代なんです　ほとんどみんな
でもこの名前変えずに活動してきて
今年で10年になります
（田村）はい10年目
（金田）ありがとうございます
（山田）紹介でも言ってもらいましたけども
北海道の町の歌を作ったりとか
あと北海道のソウルフードである
ザンギとか食べ物の歌
北海道のお店の歌などなど
色々歌ってはいるんですけれども
一番 今 活動の軸になってるのは
北海道179市町村
「町の歌」を作ることです
やっぱりこの町の歌を作ることで
北海道全体を盛り上げたいなっていう
気持ちもありました
でも その中には やっぱり
HAMBURGER BOYSの曲を聞いて
何か聞いた人の心の中に残って欲しいって
いうのは常に考えていたんですけども
まずそもそも このHAMBURGER BOYSが
北海道179市町村を作り始めた
きっかけとなった町があります
それは北海道 道南にある
鹿部町という町です
噴火湾の駒ケ岳のふもとにある
そんな町なんですけども
なぜ鹿部町の町の曲を作ることになったか
きっかけは田村次郎から
（田村）はい　私の幼なじみでですね
木村健太郎って男がいまして
彼が唇にすごい特徴がある
唇が大きい 厚いんですね
彼がそれをすごく昔から
コンプレックスに思っていたようで
でもそのコンプレックスを払拭する
いいイベント見つかったって言って
ある日私と山田さんのもとに
１枚のチラシを持って来たんです
そのチラシは何なのかというと
「鹿部たらこ祭り」という鹿部町で毎年
行われているイベントのチラシだったんです
そのイベントに同時開催
「世界たらこクチビル選手権」というものが
第１回　これが開かれると
（山田）世界で
（田村）世界たらこクチビル選手権
ここで もしエントリーして世界ナンバーワン
世界チャンピオンになることができれば
自分がずっとタラコ唇で嫌だった
このコンプレックスをついに
払拭することができるかもしれないと
だから 俺はこのイベントに出るんだって
いう風に熱く語ってくれたんですよ
そん時 ああいいじゃんいいじゃん
面白いじゃんって我々で話してたんですけど
その世界たらこクチビル選手権
どうやって優勝するかっていうと
見た目だけじゃないんです
たらこの知識 たらこの愛も色々語る
PRも大事なんですね
そのPRの時間にどうせだったら俺の友達に
こんなイカした曲を作る奴らもいるんだと
俺をナンバーワンにしてくれっていう
PRをしたいから
曲を作ってくれないかっていう
依頼を受けたの　そいつに
たらこをテーマにした１曲
作ってもらえないかって言うので
じゃあやろうかというので作ったんだよね
（山田）そうなんです
（田村）うん
（山田）その場で面白いね よし
たらこの曲作ろうということで
iPadを使ってチャチャチャっとですね
もうおおよそデモの段階では
10分ぐらいで作り上げて
こんな感じでいいんじゃないかなと
とりあえずこれ持っていって
会場で聞かせてくれよと言って
出来上がった曲が こちらのナンバーです
（音楽）
さあ 皆さんもこの曲を聴いて
北海道 道南の鹿部町 一体どんな町なのか
少しでも覚えていってください
レペゼンタラコ　スケソウダラ卵
鹿部 鹿部　Hey　Come on!
キメの細かいタラコは鹿部のタラコ
それはスケソウダラの卵
噴火湾(HEY!)　Only One(湾)
最高のタラコさNo.1
俺の唇のように潤うタラコ
君の唇も今いただこう
唯一道内農家無い(無い)
タラコがあればWonder Night
鹿部町 Shikabecho
鹿部町 Shikabecho…
白いご飯のお供にタラコ
旨さ増すため今日も働こう
携帯の待ち受け新鮮なタラコ
生まれた時からお前の虜
今じゃこの町表すカラー
と化したイカしたタラコ持つパワー
兄貴も朝飯３倍だ！
白米が美味いベストパートナー
キメの細かいタラコは鹿部のタラコ
それはスケソウダラの卵
噴火湾(HEY!)　Only One(湾)
最高のタラコさNo.1
俺の唇のように潤うタラコ
君の唇も今いただこう
唯一道内農家無い(無い)
タラコがあればWonder Night
鹿部町 Shikabecho
鹿部町 Shikabecho…
サンキュー どうもありがとう
（拍手）
お届けしたのが鹿部町の歌
『GET TARACO』でした
曲を聴いて覚えていただきたかったのは
鹿部町は「たらこ」が有名だということ
そして とてもそのたらこのキメの細かい
粒が細かいんだよというね
それを皆さんに覚えていただきたく
この曲を作り上げました
（金田）僕がこの曲で学んだことが
１個ありました
（山田 田村）何でしょうか
（金田）山田君が作ってきて
（山田）はい
（金田）「唯一道内農家無い」
鹿部って農家無いのって
（山田）そうなんですよね
漁業の町で
（田村）そう 曲を作ることでね
その町のことを我々も知るもんね
（金田）僕らも知らないよね
（山田）僕らも知らないことも
たくさんありますし
そして この曲を聴いて
あぁ 鹿部町ってこういうところなんだ
鹿部町はたらこが有名なんだ
何か一つでも覚えていただければ
それがその町を知るきっかけになり
好きになるきっかけになると
そう思ってこういった曲を作っています
先ほども話していた
世界たらこクチビル選手権に出場した
共通の友人である木村健太郎は
一体どうなったのか
（田村）どうなったんだ
（山田）結果 この曲も持っていって
バシッとたらこ愛を語ったところ
２位でした
（田村）惜しいんだよ
（山田）いいところまで行った
（田村）優勝できなかったんだよなぁ
（金田）残念だったね
（田村）でも 世界２位だから
（金田）世界２位です
（山田）世界２位です
（田村）海外の方も出られててやっぱ
なかなか分厚い唇だったらしいんですよ
（金田）海外の人居なかったんだよ
（田村）２人居たって言ってましたよ
（金田）えー居たの
（山田）居ました
（田村）そうですよ
（金田）じゃあ世界２位なんだ 本当に
（田村 山田）そうそう
（田村）マスク外した瞬間 おーって
ざわめいたらしいですからね
（山田）そう 彼の唇が
もう本当に厚い唇だったので
（田村）２位
（山田）２位となりました
ただですね そのたらこ愛をPRする時間に
この曲を流したところ
その後 そのイベントはずっと
僕らの曲をかけ続けてくれたそうです
そして大会終了後 関係者の方が
友人の木村健太郎に
あの曲すごくいいから続きを作って欲しい
全部完成させて欲しい というふうに
依頼を受けて 僕らに話がきました
僕らはその曲 今お届けした
『GET TARACO』をフル尺で作って
完成させた翌年には
「世界たらこクチビル選手権」が行われた
たらこ祭りに呼ばれて
生でその会場で歌うことができました
（金田）感動した　その時
（山田）ねー
それきっかけで鹿部町の道の駅で
僕らのたらこの曲
しいては そのたらこの曲が入ったCDが
エンドレスで流れるようになりました
正直 道の駅の人は
ノイローゼになってると思います
（田村）嫌だろうな　もうな　申し訳ないね
（金田）もう６年前とか７年前の話
（山田）一応CD新しいのを
渡しているんですけども
ずっとHAMBURGER BOYSなので
いつか行ったら「また来たのかい」って
言われるんじゃないかなと
思いながらいますけども
（金田）ちなみに未だに掛けて
くれているんですね
（山田）すごく嬉しいんです
それは 町の人達がいい曲を作ってくれたと
喜んでくれたのもそうなんですが
町の人達が僕らのファンになってくれた
そして 嬉しいことに
僕らの曲を道の駅で聴いて
今度 ライブに初めて来ましたとか
曲を通して町を知ることがあれば
曲を通して 町を通して今度
僕らのことも知ってもらえると
これ本当に僕らも音楽を通して
北海道を応援してきて良かったなと
ヒデミも申しております
（金田）僕 本当にこれ実際
ライブやって感動して
今 それが６、７年前なんですけど
今ではもう20曲ぐらいは—
それをきっかけにして曲を作ったので
北海道市町村が20曲くらい
僕ら今 持ち曲があると
で各地やって 喜んでいただいてっていうのが
続いてるんですよ
（山田）そうなんですよね
やはりあとはいい曲を作る 覚えてもらう
というのが絶対的に大事なんですけども
皆さんにそのきっかけを作る—
全ては伝えることは絶対できないと思います
どこか一つ心にきっかけを作りたいと思ったり
曲を作っているんですが
大条件として
キャッチーな曲ではなきゃいけないと
キャッチーであること　覚えやすい
思わず口ずさんでしまう
そんなメロディーや歌詞というのを
心がけているんですけども
それを制作する上で
最も大事にしているものが
最初の閃きです
閃きというとインスピレーション
という言葉がはまりますけども
人と会った時の第一印象の
ファーストインプレッション
それに近いものもあります
曲と出会った時のその感触
降りてきた言葉の感触からメロディーを作る
その場で思い浮かんだアイデアっていうのは
すごいパワーを持ってると思います
シチュエーションが違っても悩んだ時に
一番最初に自分がどう思ったか
どう動いていたかは初心に帰るという意味でも
最初の考えに戻るのもいいですし
とにかく人生の壁にぶち当たった
そんな時は
己を信じてあの一番最初に
思いついた そのアイデアを活用して
これからも もし僕らの音楽も通して
一緒に切り開いていけるのであれば
是非皆様も最初に思い浮かんだ
アイデアというのは
忘れないようにしていただきたいと思います
では そんなアイデア満載な
HAMBURGER BOYSの
北海道を応援する曲で
最後は締めていきたいと思います
『旅コミュニケーション』
（音楽）
僕らの曲を通して北海道を
まだまだ知っていってください
そして 北海道いろいろなところに
お出かけしていきましょう
HAMBURGER BOYSの
お出かけナンバーで最後締めたいと思います
レッツ シンギン
旅コミュニケーション
ちょっと出かけよう でっかいどう北海道
ナイスなロケーション 旅コミュ二ケーション
美味しい旅でしょ?
君とバケーション いえー
来週の休みは何する?
君の口から出た言葉をスルー
突然のクエッションに戸惑う
当日決めるの絶対にタブー
わかった! すぐ情報収集
ネットやテレビたまにYouTube
温泉 グルメ 宿も予約
仲良しこよし君とチューチュー
出かける前はタイトな２人も
食べさるもんさ現地のうまいもん
ついつい寄っちまう道の駅
ついつい酔っちまう道連れ
炭水化物ばっか目に入る
完全スイーツは別に入る
食べすぎ飲み過ぎ胃のもたれ
結局温泉は時間が切れ
社長さんとパスタ へべれけコッペパン
パンチェッタって何すか? 豚バラの事さ
食レポ?食レポ? このジンギスカン撮った?
食レポ?食レポ? おれジンギスカン食った?
ちょっと出かけよう でっかいどう北海道
ナイスなロケーション 旅コミュ二ケーション
美味しい旅でしょ?
君とバケーション いえー
サンキュー どうもありがとう